[Music]
I'm gonna find the one piece
it's called Roger's treasure
he headed somewhere in the grand line
it's a myth can't wait to see the look
on your face when we find it
but isn't there something that you want
[Music]
more than anything else in this world
for as long as I can remember
it's been my dream to become
[Music]
King of the Pirates
treacherous path
if
it's too easy then you're on the wrong
path
Scourge upon this world
we will capture them
and they will be brought to Justice
[Applause]
[Music]
don't let anything get in the way of
your dreams
[Music]
not everyone gets to follow their dreams
foreign
until we find the one piece
and become king of the Pirates
[Music]
I'm telling you actually believe in him
I don't need to he believes himself
[Music]
I'm afraid it's time I ended this
that went pretty well
don't you think
[Applause]
[Music]